[Música]
hasta ahora los esfuerzos diplomáticos
por eliminar la posibilidad de una
invasión de rusia a ucrania se han
quedado en el compromiso exterior de
vladimir putin que insiste en que no
tiene intención de iniciar una guerra
con el país respaldado por eeuu y
también por la otan en los últimos
acercamientos el presidente de francés
emmanuel macrón trajo a coalición los
acuerdos demmings del grupo de normandía
que se firmaron a partir de la anexión
de la península de crimea a rusia esto
en el año 2014
weimer putin dice que esos pactos siguen
siendo violados y ha dejado entrever que
su cumplimiento podría hacer por el fin
de rebajar esta atención cinco años
después de la firma porque son tan
importantes vamos al análisis con
alexander es el leaf analista político
del instituto ucraniano para las
relaciones internacionales gracias
alexandre por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de francia 24 me
pregunto por la importancia entonces de
estos acuerdos de mix firmados tras la
anexión de crime y porque estos acuerdos
no han logrado desde escalar esta crisis
hola buenos días gracias por su pregunta
por primero hay que entender que hay que
los acuerdos de minsk hay dos cuando
demi es como dos documentos del primero
fue firmado el en angels y tiene dos
años el 2014 después de que las tropas
rusas cruzaron la frontera ucraniana y
tuvo y hubo batallas de gran escala pues
la primera
la primera el primer objetivo fue fue
será hostilidades en el este de ucrania
y establecer la estabilidad de la zona
del conflicto pero finalmente no logró
el alto del fuego por completo y las
batallas continuaron pues después de ese
primer documento fue firmado el segundo
protocolo de el segundo documento de
minsk
después de las negociaciones de los
líderes del cuarteto de normandia
alemania francia ucrania y rusia en el
fútbol formato 4ta de norman y también
cuenta el objetivo fue desde esa
escalada del conflicto pero aquí hay que
entender es muy importante e incluye ese
es esos documentos de su propio top
protocolos de minas por primer es la
adopción de la ley sobre el orden
especial para esta región de donbass en
el este de ucrania
que fue finalmente fue
complementado por ucrania ucrania lo
hizo por segundo es dirigida de las
fuerzas fuerzas armadas ilegales equipos
militares militantes y y mercenarios que
rusia no completó finalmente porque
ahora mismo los las tropas rusas a las
tropas bajadas por rusa de las
mercenarias rusas están actuando en en
tumbas
y por tercero es garantizar de las
elecciones locales en tumbas el
protocolo de mismo habla sobre las
elecciones locales en donde esto es muy
importante porque eso es la principal
controversia entre el granero porque
ucrania insiste que las elecciones
locales pueden
celebradas solo después de él
cuando el invierno ucrania de un coreano
recupera el control de la frontera con
rusia sólo después es posible hacer
hablar celebrar las elecciones locales
que vayan a hacer
correctos y legales y este razonable por
mi opinión es totalmente razonable a
esta posición del gobierno ucraniana
rusia por contra contrario insiste que
es posible a celebrar las elecciones y
otorgar el estatus especial a donbass
solo y sólo después el gobierno
ucraniano puede encontrar la frontera
con rusia pues es lógico que si en sus
elecciones van a ser controladas por las
tropas rusas si antes bajó de su presión
oleksandr una pregunta entonces teniendo
estos acuerdos ya firmaron dos acuerdos
demmings no solamente es uno entonces
con esto que está en sobre la mesa se
puede solucionar este conflicto entre
rusia y rusia y ucrania por la vía
diplomática hay una posibilidad de poder
solucionar este conflicto
diplomáticamente claro sí sí
pero aquí hay en todas partes y rusia
también debe respetar los intereses de
su visado y rusia por ahora no no está
abierta a unas negociaciones porque es
eso es este protocolo fue firmado bajo
la presión militar
bajo ese chantaje militar cuando el
ejército ucraniano fue rodeado por las
tropas rusas en el año en 2014-2015
es normal que es posible revisar el
documento porque ahora es el status quo
es diferente pero rusia no lo quiere
rusia está en el mismo posición quien en
el en el 2014 pues el diálogo está
bloqueado el diálogo diplomático está
bloqueado y no hay yo no veo ninguna por
por eso por ahora no yo no veo ninguna
ningún desarrollo en este en este caso
alexandre hablemos del papel que ha
jugado la comunidad internacional
realmente cuál podría ser un mediador
clave en este conflicto para buscar
realmente soluciones y ver realmente una
desescalada porque a pareciera también
que en las últimas horas pues de todo se
echó a perder toda la pues digamos el
esfuerzo que pudo haber hecho el
presidente francés emmanuel macrón con
lo que vemos en el día de hoy
sí gracias es una pregunta de verdad muy
muy interesante porque la comunidad
internacional no debe tolerar esa
agresión de rusia y quiere la paz y
estabilidad energía y ucrania
si vamos a ver y considerar el protocolo
de minsk a la lectura rusa eso no va a
la paz no va a reinar en este país en
esta región eso no es sobre la
estabilidad hay que la comunidad
internacional debe apoyar la posición de
ucrania porque ucrania según víctima de
ese conflicto y hay que finalmente hay
que también celebrar una reunión del
cuarteto de normandia y rusia no quiere
hacer porque la última vez cuando se
elaboraron esa reunión fue el final del
imagínate hace dos años y por ahora no
no hay ninguna posibilidad de celebrar
otra reunión porque usted no no la
quiere porque dice que hay que sí
oleksandr muy brevemente que podemos ver
entonces en los próximos días cómo están
las cosas en la actualidad
y después de la visita de macrón ese día
lo que
empezó finalmente y ahora empezamos la
visita del canciller de alemania hola
scholtz aquí y para moscú y pienso que
hay algunas opiniones que esa reunión de
norma va a ser celebrada muy pronto
puede ser que ese año sólo después
podemos ver el resultado pues yo estoy
seguro que eso el conflicto va a ser va
a ser solucionados por la a través de
instrumentos de combate